I flew all the way to Austin Texas to
meet with the pound-for-pound goat of
Jiu Jitsu it's Gordon Ryan on this
week's food truck Diaries I'm feeding
them CM smokehouse barbecue and your
boys cooking
let's go
[Music]
the king is in the building Mr Gordon
Wright how you doing brother good how
are you guys how you doing man can't
complain I can't complain God you look
good dude it's the Austin Air I think
I'm trying I'm just trying to get to
these last two weeks of camp and then uh
we'll be home free from there how you
feeling obviously you've been pretty uh
transparent about you know your stomach
issue stuff like that not only competing
you know at the highest level in Jiu
Jitsu and doing it you know the best
ever do it I feel comfortable seeing
that the best ever think so yeah yeah I
think anybody who says otherwise is an
idiot but uh you know so you're
competing not only against the top juicy
guys in the world but also convenient
against yourself with your body but your
body so you got to deal with both those
things you know yeah I definitely I feel
a lot better now for sure
um
you know my stomach I talked about a
million times my stomach got so bad I
wasn't even able to not even train but
just like function as a normal human
being like the first time I did Rogan I
was so nauseous I have like no
recollection of what we even talked
about because I was just like come on
man hold it together hold it together I
remember watch out and be like hey he
drinks a lot of water because you just
sipping water I was sipping water
because I was about I was about to throw
up I'm like come on just like push it
down push it down see every time I'd
stop talking I'd have to just like sip
water sip water and then finally like
we're like two and a half hours in and
I'm like oh it's subsided and then like
Rogan's like all right man thanks so
much you don't want to hit a bug in the
night before because I think that was
your first time doing that GRE you don't
hit him up like hey man my stomach hurts
I'm not gonna make it well that's the
thing they don't realize when you say
your stomach hurts not like me where
it's whatever you know I like your tummy
ache yeah your [__] is serious so it was
like I hadn't really met him before that
and we never hung out and I just I was
living in Puerto Rico at the time I was
actually looking for houses in Austin
because if you talk to Rogan for more
than a half hour you have to move to
Austin that's like a rule yes um that's
why I hang up at 28 seconds 28 minutes
in dude so then uh you know it was like
the first time we ever really hung out
and I was on the podcast and I'm like
man I cannot tell Joe Rogan that I can't
do his podcast because I have a belly
egg I'm like I gotta just powered
through it but I can't make it man
stomach hurts yeah but I've been on this
street but now with uh this guy Dr my
bar actually in La
um and uh it's like 80 85 better now so
it's a lot better than it was and I can
at least manage it for competition so
yeah that's why you know uh when we
decided to do the food truck I was like
because I have to be careful what I eat
because I have psoriasis it just flared
up I don't know what the hell's going on
uh it's autoimmune disease so I can't
eat certain things now too so with the
pink in the food trucks is dicey and
then I was just selfishly thinking of
myself and then I hit me literally three
days ago like oh well the [__] normal
Kitty oh what are we gonna do man just
the worst food truck ever we can't eat
yeah no one can eat you're eating
carrots I mean like a [__] lettuce
I'm confident enough to eat food trucks
left now but I'm not confident enough to
do it during an interview smart because
I'm eating it I'm like oh man I'm
getting a little nauseous and then I
kind of just snowball then you get
anxiety because you're trying to talk on
camera and I'm like oh man so I'm I'm
actually fasted all day just for this
and then I'm gonna just pick out dude
you're the best brother you're the best
well hope it's not too bad it's actually
freezing in Austin yes for those
watching this right now uh you know I'm
an L.A kid I guess you're used to the
cold in New Jersey yeah right because in
New York it's a little windy a little
cold out here so we're gonna take it
inside brother and finish this inside
and we're also going to order food that
hopefully doesn't flare up my spot to
flip up your stomach we're getting older
man we're just getting old now let's do
it brother
[Music]
how you doing brother good how y'all
doing today appreciate you doing this
man yeah for sure get a great setup here
I'm gonna we both have issues uh it's
worse than mine I'll take my Spots I'm
feeling I'm feeling confident now to be
honest so oh my God I'm gonna go off The
Rocker today bro if this goes south
don't be mad at me dude I'm not
encouraging this I'll do your uh your
wagyu Burger all right cool yeah can I
just have the uh just a regular
cheeseburger with just uh mayonnaise and
lettuce yeah and uh french fries oh you
go with fries can I have a medium well I
got you perfect thank you perfect
brother yeah thanks for doing this man
for sure I'll bring it out thank you
yeah I think you're seriously
[Music]
every day
all right my man got your G when's the
last time we had a cheeseburger
uh I've been feeling pretty good lately
it's probably been about a week okay but
there was like a four year period where
I couldn't eat cheeseburgers at all so
now you're doing I'm trying to make up
for it now my stomach's failing okay man
I'm so nervous and they just sick it
won't though man now the big news came
out with flow Sports yeah that you
signed the first ever for Jitsu seven
figure deal
I mean that's a historic and Jitsu man
you're kind of uh you know you're the
you're the chosen one to carry this
sport in the mainstream yeah yeah so
it's um
it's a one year uh non-exclusive uh
seven figure deal uh for them and uh
yeah I think that
doing big deals like this and making
them public I think helps obviously
bring a lot of eyes to the sport
helps everyone get paid uh and uh
it's just good overall for us for the
longest time
there just wasn't the ability for anyone
to make any money through Jiu Jitsu
unless I started fighting or unless they
owned schools or they just spend all
year teaching seminars uh but now we
have at least one guy in the sport who
can make like I guess real athlete money
that's all you need because you open up
the gate just competing yeah now you've
got a certain level to you know you've
obviously earned it but I think you know
for for the naysayers the haters out
there it's like oh you don't realize
this this him getting the seven figure
deal helps all you all you guys like we
need this for the sport to grow and it's
you know you just have to be the guy who
has the personality has the look and
obviously clearly has the skill set
where you're drawing attention from not
just kind of this Niche Jiu-Jitsu
Community you're you're drawing
attention from you know the the Casual
fan you know
but you need guys like you yeah and it's
rare they come around but you're the guy
that heavy lies the crown that's a lot
of pressure I'm sure yeah we need jiu
jitsu
to bridge the gap from being a
participant sport where most people who
watch Jutsu also participate in Jiu
Jitsu to a spectator sport where most
people who watch Jiu Jitsu don't do Jiu
Jitsu or a lot of people don't do Jiu
Jitsu like people who most people watch
UFC
aren't showing up the next day to get
punched in the head by their buddies so
like so we need we need a lot more
people who don't do Jiu Jitsu who are
watching it just because they're a fan
of the sport or they're a fan of you
know one of the athletes so I think it's
and uh clear you know with you how
dominant you are people love a winner no
matter what it is you know you like
Tiger Woods look the way you do for golf
golf golf was dead for how many years
and then tiger comes around he's just
dominating and you know he has a certain
look and he's electric and they
gravitated more of the general fans over
so you're kind of like the Tiger Woods
of Jiu Jitsu you knew that Tiger Woods
to Tony Hawks and either Michael Jordan
like you need I know he's a better
example yeah like you need at least the
one guy in the sport that's going to
transcend and
push the sport further than
the athlete goes further than what the
sport is supposed to be and I I think
the biggest thing
not the problem is just you know it
takes time is educating the fan base
like the general you know consumer of
mixed martial arts when the fight goes
to the ground like oh come on get back
to the feet rip his hat off it's like no
no it's actually really cool what
they're doing down there so just
educating the people of this chess chess
match and the high level of grappling
well that's the thing is
you're never going to have as high of
ceiling
with Jiu Jitsu or grappling art as you
will with striking Arts because someone
gets punching the punch in the face it's
easy to understand we can all understand
yeah
um so like you just it was never going
to be as big as
you know MMA uh it won't even be in the
same
same ballpark you don't need it but you
don't need it to be because that's
that's the thing
um you know you just need to big enough
wear
you can make real money as an athlete
and there's so many people involved in
the sport where if you do teach a
seminar you can charge a lot of money if
you do make an instructional a lot of
people are going to buy it correct um
and there's a lot more ways to generate
money in jiu jitsu
than there is an MMA like if you're a
fire in MMA you basically just fight and
then you know maybe do appearances here
and there if you're an outlier you have
like some big endorsements we got to be
a real house yeah yeah
um but jitsu who can make money even
after your retire because you can teach
like there's not really a big market for
teaching MMA because most casual fans
don't want to punch in the face aren't
the kids getting punched in them yes yes
um but Jitsu like if you can if I
compete until I'm 40 I can continue
teaching for the rest of my life and
then that kind of
that even after my competitive career I
can still generate Revenue yeah yeah so
uh you know it's definitely different uh
and it takes longer to make money and
you don't make as much money in your
Prime as an athlete as a high-level MMA
fighter but you can generate money for a
lot longer yes over yeah over a long
period of time but also it you know it's
like if the UFC who you know who's the
Catalyst of kind of mixed martial arts
they're basically the you know they're
the kleenex of tissue paper right when
people like we'll go oh do you do UFC
that's how big the sport is right so
especially the UFC if they would just
put the same promotional
ton of assets into you or these
high-level Jutsu players instead of the
slap Fight League I was just gonna say
I'm trying to get the slap by promotion
we need that slap fight the same Vibes
the slap bite gets into into what you're
doing the slap fight and then when I was
talking to the fight pass guys they're
like what do you want I'm like man I
want the same kind of marketing that
gets Paddy pimlet two million Instagram
followers every week it gets it deleted
he like gets his Instagram deleted for
saying something and then the next week
he has two million followers the next
week is three million followers and he
gets it deleted again I'm like that's
kind of marketing I want yeah you guys
gonna bump my shadow man up
don't get me started with with uh it's
like I think that's one of the reasons
I'm triggered by the slap type league
and I'm not knocking the guys that do
that like God bless you you know them
doing that is insane I I would never
[__] do that but you know they're
putting their their brains on the line
there and it's kind of the shock Factor
but the reason I'm triggered by is
because I know guys like you and I you
know been used to team for a while and
I've seen MMA fighters around like uh if
you guys would just focus on the there's
so many great stories out there good
people have worked years and years and
years to get this kind of Spotlight on
them like do that man don't look for the
quick Buck it's crazy a lot of the slot
bike guys I met them at the pi and a lot
of them do Jiu Jitsu and uh I met like
both teams and like oh man what's up
Gordon I was like Hey guys like I didn't
know how you know me but they're like oh
man like I'm a purple belt I did [__]
um so I met those guys they're they're
cool and I saw a lot of like behind the
scenes stuff with them filming
and uh it's definitely interesting for
sure
um but if Jiu Jitsu can get that kind of
marketing uh that's all we need the UFC
invest like heavily into grappling which
I think they are now thankfully
um that's gonna be that'll just
completely change the sport overnight
what's up fam let's take a little break
from chatting with the goat of Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu I'm back in Calabasas now but
I had a great time in Austin chatting
with my straight up boy now we're
talking about Gordon Ryan and listen if
you want to look like Goran Ryan you
need to get your meal plan right need to
eat right this new year you've got goals
maybe without the same as Gordon Ryan
but you got some pretty high goals you
want to set for yourself and my friends
at Factor are here to help you achieve
each and every single goal that you have
fuel up fast with ready nutritious meals
delivered straight to your door leaving
you time and energy to tackle everything
on your to-do list like in better Jiu
Jitsu all right achieve and maintain
your 2023 goals with Factor America's
number one ready to eat meal kit and
start saving time eating well and live
living your best year yet too busy to
cook say less Factor go ahead and skip
the trip to the grocery store and Skip
The Chopping prepping cleaning all right
uh factors fresh never frozen meals are
rating just two freaking minutes all you
have to do heat up enjoy it takes all
the guesswork out no matter what your
lifestyle Factor has delicious flavored
packed meals to help you live a fullest
fullest diet that whatever you're on
whether it's keto calorie smart vegan
veggie Protein Plus what your thick
friend does here because I have
psoriasis all right with 34 Chef
prepared dietitian approved weekly
options there's something always new to
try out want to cut back on takeout get
Factor instead not only is Factor
cheaper than take out but meals are
ready fast on restaurant delivery in
just two freaking minutes all right so
get Factor enjoy clean eating without
the hassle simply choose your meals and
enjoy fresh flavor flavor packed meals
delivered right to your door rating just
two minutes no prep No Mess head to
factor meals.com slash job50 that's
Schaub 5-0 use the code shop 50 to get
50 off your first box
that's code chop50 at Factor meals
f-a-c-t-o-r-meals.com shop50 to get 50
off your first box
doctor
agree and and you have athletes you have
the personalities you have the
drama you know there's the story lines
there
it just it makes so much sense to me
maybe uh to do it when you talk about
the being in Vegas being at the UFC uh
was it the is the API is that what they
call it is it apex apex apex API oh
shoot a commercial for rain with a Thor
big Thor from Game of Thrones you know
and he comes back and this just shows
it's like this is a you know casual fan
or whatever and obviously knows who you
are and we're sitting down and he's like
oh you know who I who I Ruled with
yesterday I'm like oh he's like Goran
Rhino how'd that go and he's like man
and he was baffled this is just and it's
just it's not his fault it's just
ignorance is worse he's like man he like
I thought I would be able to like
control him and hold him down like
Gordon run Thor and he's he's my boy I
was like you you thought you were going
to do well he's like I'm so much bigger
and I have to be like I get underneath
him to hold them down like that's insane
dude I started laughing he's like why
are you laughing I'm like I I'm laughing
because I can't believe you thought you
were gonna do well he was like that's
messed up I'm like no it's not that be
like playing Jordan one-on-one like I
dude I can't believe I didn't get a shot
off it's like really it's just he
doesn't know we were drilling uh side
control escapes with him and Martin so
I'm like what do you guys want to do so
like okay we they're like we're just
gonna leave it up to you
I'm like all right well
you want to see like cool stuff or do
you want to see stuff that like
you know will actually help you get
better at Jitsu they're like we want to
get better I'm like okay well
number one issue heavyweights have is
bottom position yes um so I'm like let's
do some let's let's do some I think
Martin's used to wrestle so I'm like
let's do some side control escapes into
some wrestling techniques where you
punch an underhook in you come up on
single legs move the tight way stuff
like that
it's like okay
so I started showing the moves and
instantly the second they start drilling
together
it just turns into a full roll yeah so
I'm just like I'm like guys I'm like
so Martin's that she goes to the side
control he has like full inside position
he's just squeezing as hard as he can
Thor can't move at all I'm like this is
never gonna work like unless you like
let them do it like do it like this is
just one move we're Drilling so we go we
go through Doug yeah we want to do like
an hour class it's like 10 minutes goes
by they're both exhausted because it
turns into a full roll then the camera
guy's like we want to see you roll
so I'm like oh man so I I look I look
around because I have to compete the
next day so this is something that is
worth mentioning because like in less
than 24 hours I have to compete
so I look around and I'm looking for
John because I know if John seems to be
wrong with these two guys yeah he's
gonna he's gonna freak out so I'm like
looking around the room for John and I
see he's like over in the corner like
doing toes to bar like on like lifting
weights or something on the other side
so I'm like all right let's do it quick
so like I let Thor start in side control
like full inside position he's got
everything like my arm shelf and I'm
like all right go and so like I escape I
sweep him and then I end up submitting
him and he's like man he's like I don't
know what just happened so then like
Martin's goes and Martin's like a lot
more compact than Thor yeah
built like a baby rhino he's got like
some instincts because he used to
wrestle where store never really
grappled
um so Martin's like locks into side
control oh my God man this is gonna be
worse so
I escaped Martin's side control we start
wrestling and he's like freaking out I
have him in like all good positions he's
just like rag doll be around the map and
then like 30 seconds later he gets so
tired he's like man I'm done I'm like
that was it
so then like we did a couple more rounds
and then Martin's and Thor wrestled uh
and then big Dan from our team wrestled
uh wrestled those guys and uh they kind
of made a little YouTube video out of it
but I think yeah it's a great video I
think but I think it's good for people
to see that because I think guys see
like Thor's meth listen I've been around
big guys when I saw Thor for this time
like oh that's the biggest human I've
ever seen like you're so big dude it's
out of control this is good because when
I meet like a regular person who they
just people like oh man if the guy was
just way bigger it would never work now
I can say I literally grappled the
strongest person on the planet and I
promise you Jiu Jitsu works yeah it
definitely works that's why it was
designed for it right so yeah with those
I just couldn't believe how it could
easily maneuver me and flip me I'm like
really I just I couldn't stop laughing
he was he wasn't you know he wasn't
taking the heart he was just like I
can't he's like why are you laughing
like I I'm just baffled you thought it
was gonna go well thought like that's
insane to me but he was against bored
about it he's a good dude so for you
I think I'm sure you've thought about
like obviously the Legacy you're you
know you're doing the damn thing the
most accomplished no gee Grandpa of all
time you just signed this big seven
fight or I'm sorry seven-figure deal
with floor flow Sports it's like where
and you're 27 so it's like do you see
kind of like how long you can do this
like what's the goal here you know wait
till you you're the just the face of all
of it so it depends on three things uh
number one obviously I have to stay
healthy so as long as I'm healthy which
I somehow just could never be completely
healthy with my stomach but as long as
I'm my stomach is manageable uh
and I have John as my coach I won't
compete without John as my coach
um because I feel like that makes such a
big difference
um and also Sunny runs my diet she runs
my workout she runs everything for me on
that end so if I have Sunny around if I
have John around and if I'm healthy uh I
plan to compete until I'm 40. because
that's about when you Peak
in terms of isometric strength but still
maintain good amounts of cardio and
Jiu Jitsu athletes Peak a lot later
because of the fact that most sports
like wrestling
MMA boxing they're all sports but based
on explosion whereas
grappling Jitsu uh is built around
isometric tension yeah so you don't need
that explosivity that you do in the
other sports so you Peak a lot later so
you see like someone like Andre
it's my belief that Andre was the best
Andre in 2019 ADCC you talking about
galvo yeah yeah
um it was almost as good when he fought
me but it wasn't as good as when he
fought Felipe I don't think interesting
um and he was 40 when he fought me so I
think Andre's peep was his 38 I mean he
was bigger than ever his cardio was
better than ever he was more technical
than ever
um he had that many more that many more
years of technical development so it's
my belief that you you Peak between 35
and 40 in grappling so if I can compete
until 35 40 uh I'll be happy and one of
the things I want to do which is like
almost impossible if you tell me MMA I'm
gonna freak out no
um so bushesha is the most decorated
competitor of all time in terms of
medals he's 14 IBG Jeff noogie or uh IBG
Jeff World titles yeah he's awesome uh
but the world is every year so what I
want to do is basically impossible but I
want to try it anyways if I double gold
in ADCC every year until I'm 40 I'll
have more ADCC medals than he has World
titles oh wow uh so
quite the goal it'll be almost
impossible because ADCC is almost every
two years yeah it's like every year if
you do worldly double gold and so every
year every other year you can double
golden ADCC so it takes twice as long
but I'll have like I think I'll have 15
medals I did the math one time if I
double gold every year until I'm 40 I'll
have 15 medals that's insane um so if I
could do that then I'll be like okay
then uh yeah the one thing I never want
to hear and there was rumors about it
because when he signed with one Jam ship
he did the grappling match there but
when they told me you're going to MMA I
don't like that
because and I think you're the guy who
can do this the reason why high level
Jitsu guys go to MMA which is not making
the money that they need to in Jiu Jitsu
you are and uh MMA it's like just like
anything it's like it takes years to now
you're grappling at such a high level
you can do it and the Striking could you
know figure out to make sure you're safe
but it's like no just keep being the
Michael Jordan of Jiu Jitsu because it
makes the sport look bad I think you
make just look bad when these guys jump
out of it and go to MMA yeah and I think
it actually hurts jujitsu
John has never been wrong on anything
like he'll say something to me and
whether I don't agree with it or not
like two three years later I'm like oh
wow he's right except for his fashion
tips except for that that's subjective
um but uh and so he's like he's like
you're already making a ton of money
he's like you're the greatest of all
time and he's like and YouTube's just on
the cusp of being a mainstream sport yes
he's like
if you leave now it's just going to
degenerate back until what it was unless
there's another star built which doesn't
seem like there is you [__] the game
um so he's like there's no reason for
you to move to MMA he's like you can
just continue to do this and you can
retire with a legacy that no one will be
able to be close to even touching so
oh my God that's right no he's right man
he's 100 right
um now there are guys in the sport when
you talk about you know personalities
and there's some young guys coming up
for sure but you know me my guy my team
were talking about last night a guy like
Dylan danis
you know he he kind of rose to Fame in
the Jitsu I don't think a lot of people
realize this and you'll do a much better
job educating the fans on this but Dylan
danis he's kind of rise in Juice King
when he's a brown belt correct like he
dominates a brown bat and then when he
went to Black Belt that's when like
people think he was like undefeated as a
black belt like absolutely he wasn't
he's a phenomenal Jitsu practitioner
what he did at brown belt was historic
man like great run right he was one of
the biggest one of the biggest prospects
coming into black belt the one I don't I
don't know exactly what he wanted he won
a ton of tournaments at brown belt
um and then going into black belt he
actually had a competitive match with me
at ADCC 2017.
uh and then I think he won nogi pans
double gold at black belt so he it was
at some point he was pretty legitimate
compared to the rest of the guys in the
world
um
and then you know he started training
with Connor and then from there is his
athletic career kind of just fell off
um and
anyone's free to fracture fact check
this at bgj heroes.com uh Dylan's
competitive record uh competitive record
at black belt is 18 wins and 16 losses
yeah so he started pretty strong through
brown belt he built up through brown
belt
had a good run at brown belt got to
Black Belt was always competitive with
the best guys early in his career
but could never beat the best guys and
then after that he started working with
Connor and he stopped training with
Marcelo and then he kind of just fell
off from there do you think that's
because he wasn't all in on Jiu Jitsu
because once he went you know towards a
little bit MMA and working with Connor
like if you're not all in especially in
Jiu Jitsu at that black belt level if
you're not all in you're good it's tough
did you go 18 and 16. that's tough it's
tough and I think that coupled with the
fact that he just parties way too much I
don't think he like really trains
consistently anymore
um so but here's what's impressed with
me tell me about this I don't know how
you feel about them dance I actually
like down dance I I don't agree with
some of the stuff that he does and stuff
like that but as a human being the
interaction I've had with him he's a
good guy he pays way too much attention
to comments and I think he's you know
he's kind of lost track of what he
really wants you know if he's trying to
find that lashes out but I think deep
down good person just needs some
direction
um
my thing with with Dylan is think about
it he hasn't competed on the last time
he's competed if you if you think about
like top 10 names that are brought up in
just Combat Sports in general he has to
be up there yeah like he's always put
himself into like the what was it the
KSI fight or the he's always always
staying relevant now I don't know how he
makes money I don't know how that works
if you're not competing but he's always
relevant there has to be something to it
where it's like marking wise like again
he's falling out whatever two three
fights now and so it's getting a little
bit tough for him but we're just talking
about how impressive it is whether you
like it or not how he's always
always trending if there's one thing
that owns an absolute Master app it's
staying relevant without actually doing
anything yes
um so you gotta go appreciate the hustle
if you can't give him credit for
anything you can at least give him
credit for that like
he's he stays relevant whether he's
fighting people whether he's whether
he's scheduling matches that he's not
going to take like whatever whatever you
have to say about Dylan he definitely
does a great job we're talking about
right now
so uh you know and then he got into the
fight with khabib I get like five to ten
thousand followers overnight and I'm
just like man like he's not doing
anything but he's relevant so you gotta
at least give him credit for that and I
like the troll them all the time
um but you don't like to have a real
issue with it like you the level you're
at you're like because he hasn't
competed in Jutsu at that level you're
at so it doesn't really get you out of
bed to compete against him like he's not
even I think I think Dylan genuinely
doesn't like me because when I attack
him it's like just based off like I like
post statistics and like I like I talk
like about what what's actually going on
so I know that it hurts him where he
can't really say anything about me
because I just win all the time yeah
it's uh I I think that he genuinely gets
hurt when I attack him so he doesn't
actually like me but I don't have a
problem with him I just think like
he's very good at doing the marketing
side of things but if you're very good
at talking
you don't actually compete and you can't
win then I just think you're a clown
yeah like winning is the hard part the
marketing stuff is the easy part see a
great and I I think I'll defend Dylan a
little bit here where it's like all
right you got the marketing down dude
you do have the skills to compete at a
high level and can you know whatever you
want to do with it whether it's coaching
whatever get involved with the camp
so just focus on that man get away from
all the social media hoopla and start
focus on that that's hard though
it's the hardest thing to do in the
world do you does he want to live that
hard life but he's gonna have to because
you can't just keep making these
promises and then not showing up well
the thing is I think Dylan has a lot of
family money I could be wrong because
he doesn't teach he doesn't compete
how can he generate Revenue he doesn't
have sponsors yeah he doesn't post like
on his Instagram he hasn't
post-sponsored isn't it amazing so how
the only way that I can see him having a
stream of Revenue is by having family
money or like he invested in Bitcoin
like 2010 and now he's the billionaire
like there's no other way like uber like
10 years ago or some [__] so like unless
I don't know unless it's one of those
things there's no way he can generate
money because he doesn't fight he
doesn't teach he doesn't have sponsors
so yeah I don't know what he's doing but
it's impressive he's definitely staying
relevant somehow we're talking about it
but enough about Dylan Dennis man
talking to Goat here this episode of
food truck dies with Gordon Ryan the
goat is brought to you by of course the
goat of supplements I'm talking about on
it on it.com job you save 10 off the
best supplements the best workout gear I
was just at their facility in Austin
working my little tail off they got
everything popping their daddy go check
out their gym get a gym membership get
your thick ass in shape there's no
excuses for those of you that can little
use a little Turbo on your brain there
check out Alpha Brain the number one
nootropic on the planet they sell it at
Walmart but help your boy out go to
audit.com shop save 10 off Alpha Brain
now I start with Alpha Brain like the
rest of you like the common folk out
there and I made the leap to Alpha Brain
Black Label it's more intense it's for
those do-gooders out there Alpha Brain
Black Label is the best nootropic on the
freaking planet supercharge your brain
and start shooting out sentences you
never thought were capable for you all
right that's on it.com shop temp shop
the entire site including Alpha Brain
Alpha Brain Black protein workout gear
Stream Fitness we got it all audit.com
job 10 off if you've been a consumer of
any show that I do you know I only
recommend products that I actually
personally use whatever it's it's rain
whether it's Rogue nicotine whatever it
is your boy's using it and when it comes
to Kratom I trust only one company I
trust one company only I use it
personally every single day no matter
what show I'm doing we're talking about
happy hippo Kratom that's Happy Hippo
Kratom happyhippo.com use the promo code
thick23 thick with three C's that's t h
i c c 23 you save 20 off the entire
lineup your boy uses the concentrated
shots that's right I use their uh Cherry
shot they have the new butterscotch shot
but you can get in gummies you can get
in powder everyone get your Kratom into
your body happy hippo has the best
Kratom on the planet so go and get you
some all right it's my Limitless bill I
don't do a single thing without Kratom
from Happy Hippo again that's
happyhippo.com promo code is thick
t-h-i-c-c-c-23 you save 20 off use that
code as many times you want share with
your friends your aunt your uncle
whoever you want that's thick 23
happyhippo.com now let's wrap this show
up let's get back to the program
um I think what would be good for you
you've mentioned it is the ultimate
fighters coming back talk about Ultimate
Fighter alumni season 10 biggest season
of all time not a big deal it's fallen
off since then it's you know it's on
ESPN plus nobody's watching but now you
have Connor and Michael Chandler now
I've heard you mention I don't know if
it was the area or whatever interview
you did where you'd like to be Ultimate
Fighter coach I think that would do so
much good for you because he had so many
eyeballs and you're obviously a clearly
good coach you speak well you look the
[__] part I I don't you know I don't
know if Connor's using Dylan but I know
Chandler really well I'll text his ass
right now it's not a challenge my boy
I'll text like hey if you don't use my
boy Gordon never call me again so I
posted that
and I was like man how awesome would it
be if they had like
spin-off where you know I was like
Chandler's coach and Dylan was Conor's
coach and then they fought and then we
had a grappling match on on Fight Pass
but I was like that'd be tough because
that would mean Dylan would actually
have to show up and compete so in the
event that you can actually get Dylan to
fight me it would make sense but it
doesn't make I mean I would I would help
coach either one of them either way but
but you'd be down to do it but for sure
yeah I'd have to just move around some
competition schedules but if I if you
have the opportunity to coach with
Chandler and McGregor on Alpha fighter
that's a big opportunity and I don't
know definitely why either of them
wouldn't use you like you know Connor
appreciates like Elite high level [__]
clearly and then Mike Chan was such a
good person I'm I'm sure one of them's
gonna be down for I'm telling you we're
gonna take a picture I'm gonna send to
chail I'm like dude if you don't [__]
hire I'm ready I'm gonna freak the hell
out you know it makes sense yeah I think
you'll just add to the hype of the show
because Ultimate Fighter and I hate to
see it it's just it's just hasn't been
doing well but having Conor and Chandler
on there and now it's not only is he
it's not gonna be just behind ESPN plus
paywall it's gonna be on regular ESPN so
the amount of views and like what you're
doing for juicy like you have the
greatest of all time doing the damn
thing and he's a coach on here and they
tell your story I think it'd be great
yeah and all the kids on the show know
who the hell you are then I know they're
they're doing a part where I I'm pretty
sure they're bringing guys back that had
a shot at the UFC it didn't go well so
they're like a Redemption story okay
yeah I remember watching that Redemption
one with Matt Sarah on it when I was
like nine years old yes yes
uh I'll I'll end on some of this stuff
because I need to get back to training
I'm I can't tell you the anxiety I have
watching eat your food and how I'm
praying to God it doesn't [__] up your
day because you're never gonna talk to
me again my stomach's been okay the fans
are gonna watch this and they're gonna
look at it they're gonna be like I knew
it his stomach was never [__] up the
whole time he was lying the whole time
that made this whole thing yeah yeah
he's made this whole thing up yeah I'm
doing I'm doing a lot better I ate a
full cheeseburger and fried double
cheeseburger and fries so yeah I'm
definitely getting a lot better God I
hope it goes well I have the worst
anxiety
um just going back to to how I always
find it interesting like your journey to
get to where you're at now we are
considered the greatest ever do it
growing up in New Jersey you didn't
start Jiu Jitsu you're 15 right yeah the
did anybody see this coming like were
you a football player like where's
where's this come from because it's not
like Jiu Jitsu in Jersey how long ago
you when you're 15 you're 27 now so it's
not like it was this big like huge thing
it wasn't yeah I um
so like
I've talked about this before
I got into
an interest in fighting and grappling
because uh
our daycare teacher
uh who just played like high school
basketball never did any combat or
anything uh he used to watch UFC and
listen to Rogan commentate moves
and he'd come into daycare and he'd be
like this is a Kimura or like this is a
rare naked and how old are you like
seven this guy's awesome and he's like
all right now practice it somebody like
practice submissions he's like he was
like try to give us the breakdown of
this Mission based on Rogan's commentary
and we practice that and then we all
Circle up and we have like King of the
Hill we're like we'd all Wrestle and the
first person that had submitted loses
the winner stays in and the next person
line goes in so we had like two kids
washing the door to make sure the boss
doesn't come and have like a fight club
inside the daycare and uh
so then I was like beating up my friends
for years just like you know grappling
and were you dominating that right away
I was I would be at my friends at
daycare yeah yeah so then he's
undefeated in this [__] schoolyard so
then exactly so then when I was like 15
I saw
a sign for jiu jitsu I was shopping in
my uh with my mom in the mall like a
shopping mall then I saw a big Jiu Jitsu
sign and I was like Mom I want to start
training and so at the time I started
training under a guy
um Haas who owned this school he's a
brown belt on the Ricardo made it at the
time and then I had my first coaches of
blue belts his uh Miguel Benitez and uh
you know I started training under those
two Miguel was like my main coach
because Haas wasn't there A lot of times
and you're 15. that's 15. and then uh
you know I was training there for a
couple years and then I met Tom the
blast and then I met Gary tonan and then
uh and I started training getting Gary
took the school over and then I started
training with Gary full-time and then
Gary started going to the city he met
John because he was helping Frank Yeager
with a camp yeah uh and then I started
going to the city with John and then we
kind of just moved on and then
eventually started training with John
full time when I was like 19 18 19 years
old and that was just off to the rate
when when did was there a time you knew
you're just kind of this outlier
um so I was always for like my age
Division and for like my belt level I
was always doing well like I was
competing well I was beating black belts
as the blue belts
um but I never really had any
International level success where I won
like a big tournament until like I won
Nookie world that brown belts
um and then the conference where I
really knew that I was gonna be one of
the best guys was uh was ebi 6 where I
fought Yuri uh who was the reigning ADCC
champion at the time
I was like 185 pounds that year it was
like 230 and I ended up strangling them
in overtime and then I fought Roost them
right after that who was the uh who was
the current ADCC bronze medalist and I
strangled him in overtime and I I just
got my black belt and I knew that I was
like just getting started I was like I
still suck at Jiu Jitsu but I just beat
the current 80cc Champion here we go um
so I was like okay you know this you
know this is getting serious now like I
can definitely hang with the best guys
in the world and then I had the match
with Keenan which was no time limit and
I submitted Keenan and I was like all
right like yeah this is different now
we're cooking so yeah so but growing up
the sport of choice was what uses this
crazy competitive kid I played like
backyard football I wrestled around my
friends I did like a season or two maybe
of like uh
of like wrestling like Wrestling Camps
when I was like little uh but nothing
really serious I I always tried I've
tried to play football for a season
wasn't really into it
um so it was just really just like me
like doing like backyard fights with my
friends were you you're athletic I was
always I was always super athletic until
I started doing Jiu Jitsu because
everything in normal Athletics is like
doing that like big explosive movements
everything in Jiu Jitsu is like this so
the more I do Jiu Jitsu my ankles get
popped if I try to cut and play
basketball now I just roll my ankles
like I can't do anything athletic
anymore but I used to be athletic yeah
um now I'm just icepetually strong and I
can invert and I can bend my body in
certain things
um so I'm athletic in a different way
but not like standard like if you have
to do like an NFL athletic test yeah if
you're doing a 40 yard dash yeah it
would be atrocious
and I any any person I know in Jiu-Jitsu
doing a high level they have the highest
IQ I know Jiu Jitsu such a stinky man's
game especially the outliers like Henry
Gracie one of the smartest people I know
henzo won so much people I know Ricardo
Almeda smart Audrey's super smart uh
smart dude like there's so many of these
outliers were you you were good in
school like did you excel in school I
was clearly a smart [__] dude I was
good at things that I was interested in
like I'm like I'm like a totally zero or
100 guy so if I didn't care about it I
would just like completely neglect it
yes but if I was interested in it then I
could Excel so I was only willing to put
my really willing to put my time into
things that I was actually interested in
and you did well and yeah and so I then
I you know I was always in love
with MMA and specifically grappling
because the first UFC I ever watched was
a horse Gracie tribute so it was like
all the first ufcs of voice Grace he's
in the game yeah beating people up even
though it was like I don't know 2004 or
five yeah they were doing reruns of the
early ufcs yes and so I was like man
Jiu-Jitsu is the best yeah and so then
you're like have you seen it like yeah
yeah so then like I had like an
obsession with Jiu Jitsu from an early
age and uh you know I watched that first
UFC when I was seven years old and I
just decided like that's what I'm gonna
do when I get home so dope man and so
you know then I started I started
training YouTube because I wanted to
fight MMA and I just kept getting rope
back then like roped back into digital
like I want to win trials I want to win
ADCC then I want to win the absolute now
I want to win the Super fight it's like
every time it's something else and it
ended up working out it's not working
out yeah you create a small time but
your nickname's the king for God's sake
that was that was that was on purpose
after uh
I won the ebi it was the first time ever
experiencing like [__] talk people were
like like man how is everyone so
miserable so John gave us this whole
speech like before that on how to like
build a brand and what direction we want
to take it
and I was scrolling through Instagram
and I saw like George St Pierre's
comment section George like the nicest
guy ever ever and have you rolled with
them oh yeah all the time great yeah
yeah
with like 10 years of course great guy
so smart guy smart guy very expensive so
I see his comment section and it's like
90 hate comments and I'm just like if
these people are gonna hate on this guy
they're gonna hate them they're gonna
talk [__] about anybody so I'm like I
may as well just make as much money as I
can and say whatever I want yes I'm like
how can I piss people off the most I'm
like King Ryan that's it so I started to
call myself I love it and everyone's
like man [__] that guy and I was like
yes yes I'm doing it right I'll do it
and when you told your uh family that
you're gonna do Jitsu full time not go
to college and all that so they're on
board so my dad was my dad was skeptical
but behind it my mom told me that the
only way I could keep doing Jiu Jitsu uh
was if I also went to college so she's
like yeah I get a real job so I was like
okay whatever so right out of high
school
I've worked uh 40 hours a week at DPW
just throwing grass bags in the back of
a truck and then I would train at night
time on the weekends and then I would go
to college part-time we're at uh at
Brookdale at Community College
um
so I'll do like two to three days a week
I think at Community College and then I
did that for like two semesters and then
I won the ebi
in 2016 and like that year
because my mom's like how are you gonna
make money
so in that year I made like a hundred
thousand dollars and probably 50 of it
off the evi right it was uh 25. because
I only had two submissions in
regulations so it was possible 50 but I
made 25. and
I'm like Mom
I'm just starting my career I made more
money than you this year I just stopped
[__] going to college
I'm like I just stopped going to college
she's like yeah fine so then like so
then after the ebi I had made more money
on that night that I was making I was
making like two grand a month at DTW so
I made more money and that uh and that
night that I made working a full year
DTW and I was like man I'm rich
so I was like so I was like Mom can I
please like just stop going to college
and just you know dedicate myself to
this and I finally convinced her she's
like yeah sure so then she was fully on
board and then like a year or two later
I can register to let like Nikki drop
out of high school at like 14 yeah and
he then he started training full-time
with John and then after that they were
kind of all in and they were behind it
smart smart parents yeah I'm I want to
end on this so I was watching the flow
Sports release day
um kind of like a embedded on you it
shows you waking up and your girl's
there and she took your food and you're
eating and then you talk about how you
drive a Toyota is a Corolla you're like
because I I need suffering Monday
through Friday yes now I'm a big car guy
I'm a Gearhead I saw the cars that you
have in the garage you said you know
whatever the weekends are for
testosterone like just and you have what
do you have like a C5 C6 Corvette and
you have a GTR no so I have a uh a 2022
um
Miata Club Edition which is her she
drives that around the RF version it's
got like a whole bunch of stuff I'm
actually giving that away it's got It's
lower it has suspension everything it's
all done up love it um I have a my dad's
86 uh C4 Corvette I saw that white yeah
the white one with the Greenwood body
kit that we would always like to talk
about and uh the black rag top
um so he's had that since 87. is it like
60 000 miles yeah all original I'm doing
that forever
um and then I bought him before he died
I bought him uh the the car that he
wanted which is a 2017 uh CTS-V Cadillac
oh those are six yeah I love those
um and then I have uh the TRX which I
have today because I couldn't come to
this podcast driving a Corolla that
would have hurt my face I felt
embarrassed so I was like I gotta take
the TRX hell yeah um and then I have a
two-door Jeep which is on the way which
is going to replace her uh her Miata
when we give that away
um and then after this Pena match
because Penn is making me so much money
after I beat him up again uh there's a
1500 horsepower caval Viper uh in
Florida which I really which I'm really
considering buying do it um [__] do
it I drove in one of those things and
the one that I was in was 1900 wheel
horsepower so it's a lot faster it's
dangerous no matter how however I can
try to explain to you it won't do it
justice it's like first of all the car
feels all-wheel drive so there's like no
traction issues whatsoever and it's just
is it it stick yeah it says uh six-speed
sequential so it's like you just go
forwards and backwards
um but the one that I want runs 1300
horsepower on pump gas on 93 with a
regular six-speed and I want to like buy
it and like make it like the Batmobile
like matte black everything so is that
based out of Florida he's in Florida
right now there's a guy an old guy who
owns it in Florida I'm gonna go and
check it out after and how much we're
talking about for this thing uh he's
asking I think 175 for it so what year
is it 2017. yeah I love five percent so
they take my business yeah so my flea
Bay panel check will pay for that so I
should just have flow make the checkout
to this guy that I'm going to buy them
um and then so I can thankfully by four
in the uh please send me the link to
that car when we get out of here I'll
send you pictures so please do it's
actually Cabo's friend he's his name is
listed anywhere he just sent me pictures
he's like man he's like I'm just he's
like I'm 83 years old he's like I don't
drive it anymore it's got 800 miles on
it it's like brand new they built it in
2017 when it had seven miles and the guy
only drove it 800 miles so now I'm just
like man I'm gonna go to Florida
hopefully buy it and then drive it back
yeah drive back to Austin hopefully end
up in jail you deserve I hope the
license Plate's just like okay King Ryan
that'd be sick so pennant's thing is uh
he has this terrible joke where he calls
me chubby baby
so you're not chubby I don't even get
started so because like Gordo and like
Spanish means chubby or in Portuguese
Beach chubby so he just calls me like
chubby baby it's like just a terrible
joke sure yeah so Sunny actually got me
a license plate that says Texas and then
it says chubby baby on it I love it so
if I buy the Viper I'm gonna have the
Viper I mean the post is gonna be
thanking Felipe and it's gonna be a
license plate that says chubby baby on
the back Piper I love it I [__] love
it well uh on this show I was I'm a
sneaker super Sneakerhead guy and you're
you're a tricky one because you know I
saw the toilet curl I'm like oh man I
can't give him like some crazy shoes
originally I I team up with my guys at
uh suplex in Philly they send the Jordan
11s but in the gold on because you're
King Ryan like he's the best let's send
these from the goat to the goat and I
was like I feel like it's a little flash
of room and so I had my guys reach out
I'm like ask him what he wears them
because I wanted to wear them and you
know you met you wear some Chuck stuff
like that I want to get you off white
trucks I can't just give you a regular
[__] okay I couldn't just come out
and give you like
like oh thanks for the 40 Chuck shop uh
so these it's a kith collab with
Converse they're super rare to find if
if this one might pay for uh maybe a
month worth of gas on that new Viper
okay but it's the kith Coca-Cola club
they're super rare Cocola I drink diet
coke I don't know you know you can't
mess with it but they're dope she makes
me drink Coke Zero if I'm going to drink
it ah there you go so those are for you
my man there's some rare Kiff top Chuck
collabs
Coca-Cola yep even with it even with the
bottle the packaging is no joke from
Kiff
but those are those are a rare shoe for
a rare breed man that's awesome thank
you very much you're the goat dude I
appreciate you doing this brother and uh
please send me the link to that Viper so
if you don't get it and I probably will
or if you get one similar that's how
this goes I hear about it I was talking
to Rogan oh dude if you're gonna buy
something don't call Rogan because it'll
convince you to buy it oh no no I was
trying to convince him to buy one we
were at we're like we hung out with him
he was like doing a show at Vulcan and I
got drunk and I like just taken the vipe
like I just went for a ride in the Viper
like two days before I'm like dude I'm
telling you I'm like I'm like because he
has a plaid I'm like going from The
Plaid to the Viper it's like going from
a Miata to plot it's like it's like so
mind-blowingly fast I'm like Cowboys
here I'm like just take a ride in one
I'm like I promise I'll buy it he's like
yeah that's the problem he's like I
can't buy any more [__] cars like I
have too many cars I'm like you never
have too many cars man
sit with him I was at uh a big Ferrari
Porsche and I was at Ferrari and I get
allocated cars and they have the sf90
spider and they're super rare and the
guys like yeah the allocation ends today
and so I'm there I'm talking to Rogan I
was like yeah you know it's the highest
car I'd ever have to pay for he's like
wait what is on my sf9 spiders like man
I love an all black one I'm like really
he's like yeah uh give a guy doing like
I'm here with the Ferrari guy so I'm
like hold on let me talk to him and talk
to him he's like we have one allocation
left and I was like hey they can do it
he's like I'll take it and just there
he's like you you get one too I'm like
yeah dude I'm the one who gave you the
idea and then I said I know we're both
getting [__] I I was talking to him
about this he's like man I just ordered
a new Ferrari it's supposed to be faster
than the plaid and I don't really know
that much about Ferraris because I'm not
ready to spend the half million dollars
on a car
um but I'm like okay I'm like what which
one is it
he's like oh man I forget yeah he
doesn't know I'm like you just ordered I
sold about it no I sold over yeah right
I mean you don't know what kind yes I'm
like that's how you know you're too rich
that's why you know you're wrong I'm
like yeah like how do you just buy a
Ferrari you don't know what model it is
because I was I was stressed out I was
like I don't know dude like I'm like all
right you're right let's get him yeah
it's ridiculous man but get that Viper
you've earned it that's why the Viper is
perfect because it's only it's like 200
Grand but it's 1300 horsepower so it's
like that's what it's hard to beat yeah
I'd rather have that like I like it has
American muscle car
brand yes I love it man well you're
gonna get that Viper maybe I should
bring my GT2 RS I think that's the only
guy that could maybe keep up with your
viper on the track I have it tuned which
is insane nobody Tunes gtrs's I have a
Tunis right around a thousand horsepower
oh wow this thing's a Savage dude Savvy
you would love it I would love it yeah
anything fast I like yeah me too but uh
I can't think enough man you need Grace
to ever do it brother your best but she
appreciate you doing this brother yeah
the king pound for pound go and run